hi there good morning I'm Seth
MacFarlane the host of the Oscars if you
don't know who I am just pretend I'm
Donny Osmond you'll be fine we'll get
through this
it's a great honor to be here to
announce the nominees I'm not sure why
we don't wait till noon to do this since
the only people who are up right now are
either flying or having surgery but I
want to congratulate today's nominees
and also to congratulate those who
weren't nominated you can stop doing
interviews where you pretend that you
had such a great time making the movie
and here to help me out since there's
nothing creepier than a guy standing by
himself in Hollywood at 5 in the morning
is the lovely and talented miss Emma
Stone Thank You Seth Emma Stone is the
star of the new film gangster squad
that's a nut tree or the star that seems
more like an ensemble piece can you just
keep reading the star of the new film
gangster squad and is one of the
brightest talents of her generation some
say she's better than Meryl Streep who
who say who says that I don't know
nobody a lot of people let's just read
the nominee okay okay
the nominees will be read in no
particular order for Best Performance by
an actor in a supporting role the
nominees are Christoph vaults in Django
Unchained he's won before Philip Seymour
Hoffman in the master he is won before
Robert DeNiro in silver linings playbook
he's won before
alan arkin in Argo he has won before and
Tommy Lee Jones in Lincoln he's won
before breath of fresh air in that
category
for Best Original Song the nominees are
before my time from chasing ice music
and lyric by Jay Ralph PI's lullaby from
Life of Pi
music by Michael Danna lyric by Bombay
jaya sri suddenly from lame is robbed
music by claude-michel schönberg
lyric by herbert Kretz myrrh and Alain
Boublil everybody needs a best friend
from Ted music by Walter Murphy lyric by
Seth MacFarlane and Skyfall from Skyfall
music and lyric by Adele Adkins and Paul
Epworth uh that's kind of cool I get
nominated yeah yeah I get I get to go to
the Oscars yeah you know the the MTV
Awards once gave Michael Jackson a
Lifetime Achievement Award just so you'd
show up so I'm not saying that's what's
happening today but I kind of am I kind
of am alright alright the 2012 nominees
for Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are Sally Field in
Lincoln and Hathaway in Leigh miserab
Jacki Weaver in silver linings playbook
Helen Hunt in the sessions and Amy Adams
in the master congratulations you 5
ladies no longer have to pretend to be
attracted to Harvey Weinstein
for Best Animated Feature Film the
nominees are
Frankenweenie Tim Burton the Pirates
band of misfits peter lord wreckit-ralph
rich more ParaNorman sam fell and Chris
Butler and brave Mark Andrews and Brenda
Chapman for Best Foreign Language Film
nominees are from Austria amour from
Chile no from Canada Warwick from
Denmark a royal affair and from Norway
kontiki I read I read a more was
co-produced by in Austria and Germany
right the last time Austrian Germany got
together and co-produced something it
was Hitler but this is much better much
better
highlights fat mily recommend it so much
better yeah for adapted screenplay we
have Lucie Al Abbar and Ben Zeitlin for
beasts of the southern wild Chris Terrio
for Argo tony kushner for Lincoln David
O'Russell for silver linings playbook
and David Magee for Life of Pi these are
adapted screenplays keep in mind so that
means the writers just basically copied
stuff from Microsoft Word and and pasted
it into final draft
for Best Original Screenplay the
nominees are
John gaytan's for flight Mark Boal for
zero dark thirty
Quentin Tarantino for Django Unchained
Michael Chanukah for a more and Wes
Anderson and Roman Coppola for moonrise
kingdom for best achievement in
directing the nominees are David
O'Russell for silver linings playbook
angley for Life of Pi Steven Spielberg
for Lincoln Michael hanukkah for a more
and Ben Zeitlin for beasts of the
southern wild these are five people who
are the very best at sitting in a chair
watching other people make a movie the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role are Daniel
day-lewis in Lincoln Denzel Washington
in flight Hugh Jackman in laymen's Rob
Bradley Cooper in silver linings
playbook and Joaquin Phoenix in the
master is just a little fun fact for you
denzel's character was actually as drunk
as half of the people who are up at this
hour
guilty for uh for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role the nominees
are Naomi Watts in the impossible
Jessica Chastain in zero dark thirty
Jennifer Lawrence in silver linings
playbook Emmanuel Reva in amore and qua
Venzon a wallace in the beasts of the
southern wild at 85 Emmanuel Riva is the
oldest Best Actress nominee in Oscar
history quit Benson a Wallace is the
youngest Best Actress nominee ever she's
nine and finally we are pleased to
announce that the film selected as the
Best Picture nominees for 2012 are
beasts of the southern wild Dan Jan V
Josh Penn and Michael Gottwald
producers silver linings playbook Donna
gelati Bruce Cohen and Jonathan Gordon
producers zero dark thirty Mark Boal
Kathryn Bigelow and Megan Ellison
producers Lincoln Steven Spielberg and
Kathleen Kennedy producers Leigh miserab
Tim Bevan Eric Felner Deborah Hayward
and Cameron Mackintosh producers Life of
Pi gillnetter Angley and David Woolmark
producers a more nominees to be
determined Django Unchained
Stacy cher Reginald Hudlin and Pilar
Sivan producers and Argo grant Heslov
Ben Affleck and George Clooney producers
Argo has been nominated somebody tell
Cranston he can unclench his teeth now
Bryan I love you please join us at the
Oscars Sunday February 24th to find out
who will take home the Oscars
congratulations to all the nominees
[Applause]